non c'est halloween alors y'en a qui
détestent et fêter c'est une fête
commerciale d'autres non en tout cas
tout le monde le fait
etats unis et france alors on a joué un
petit jeu les stars se sont déguisés qui
se cache derrière chaque star essayer de
retrouver chez vous un jouet un tpm
pippen de leur merci à chaque fois on
est premiers tomes tweets
merci alors qui se cache derrière sa
majesté bicloo mme hanoune championnat
on lève bien la main la semaine dernière
vous avez été indisciplinés ça a été dit
sur twitter par les femmes semblent
assez facilement du clown heidi klum
c'est la bonne répondre à vos données ça
qu'on aime ou pas mais il joue vraiment
vraiment le meilleur à chaque fois alors
de suivante qui se cachent voilà
derrière cette photo ba live voilà ici
moi je sais alors moi je sais même pas
qui c'est de la vraie celle affiches ni
rien encore série d'activités de week
end qui ça ben bella a dit de la soeur
de j j a dit de top model et de rigolade
et de christina dit j'avoue qu'au diable
on a pu tout de moi sébastien c'est pas
grand monde c'est des it girls ça
marchait pas sur internet ça marche un
petit peu dans public peu de merde si je
suis pas débile c'est quand même pas des
stars
victoria secret's quand même oui bien
suivante turbo mais des gens connus
c'est bien à l'as cannes s écrit myriam
franchement tu m'as presse est quasi
qualit'enr bravo barbie
à l'origine cette fête il faut se
déguiser en monstres comme d'habitude le
kardashian suta poil je suis désolé mais
j'ai dit et en plus cette photo-là déjà
été fait par beyoncé il avait fait elle
avec une idée de message politique parce
qu'elle voulait c'était les barbie noire
il faut imposer des barbie noire non les
kardashian comme d'habitude on se fout à
poil ça rapporte de l'argent
c'est l'apanage du vide et tu es tonique
n'ai pas trouvé ça bah si j'ai fait la
main mais vous m'avez pas regarder à
ça c'est le charisme ça alors derrière
la finale suivante regarder la sec 8/10
lever la main à des gros céline dion et
toute la petite famille absolument rabot
daniel sedin ont alors il des américains
on a fait à ses voix paléo vous
remercions française un bain qui se
cache derrière cette française
j'avoue que on va qu'on va quand même
essayer avec je sais pas peut-être mais
j'étais là vous attend mathieu boily dit
rooney mais on est dédé absolument
heroes bravo mathieu
[Applaudissements]
cirque en coûter moins de se déguiser et
je peux dire quelque chose c'est que
lily rose la semaine dernière donc la
fille de vanessa on en a parlé ici c'est
un pic d'audience on se demande s à
marcher au pas et les manifs à la tête
elle est magnifique et intéresse
vraiment vraiment les gens les
journalistes les paparazzi monjanel
l'ancien c'est chanel suivant là c'est
intéressant ce cas là à mon avis si
daniel connaît alors lax je me penche
booba qui booba bravo catherine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
écoute du booba catherine oui et j'ai
reçu sur instagram mais non ils vous
soit aussi non ce message alors qu'une
dernière la lave ou de magali dit rien
parce que trop facile en malaisie abbas
et ayem et nabila nabila a tué c'est
shy'm n'ont plus assez assez mal non
mais non des merciers rapport parce que
maquiller soi-disant monstre elle reste
super jolie côté maintenant on met une
heure pour essaimer celle des belles
entre les balles et les moches c'est là
l'aspect rituel
ah bah y'a du boulot à elles sont crevés
après les non mais non mais la belle
naturellement